laurens je me tourne vers vous vladimir
poutine reconnaît donc ce soir les
républiques autoproclamées de la région
du dombass important de préciser on
parle de reconnaissance en parle pas de
rattachement alors très concrètement
qu'est ce que ça signifie
ça signifie qu effectivement y'a pas de
rattachement moins pour le moment mais
en tout cas ce qui est très clair c'est
qu'à partir de maintenant la russie va
signer avec ces deux républiques d
accord d'amitié et de coopération qui
auront vraisemblablement à une partie
consacrée à la défense c'est à dire qu'à
partir du moment où la russie reconnaît
ces républiques qu'elles signent un
accord de défense avec elle si l'ukraine
attaque
les républiques de donetsk de lougansk
cela signifie qu'elle s'attaquera
également à la russie directement
jusqu'à présent ce n'était pas le cas on
pouvait enfin les les ukrainiens ne ne
se gênait pas beaucoup pour bombarder
les zones de deux nièces qu'en
particulier qui est une très grande
ville et en faisant des morts dont on ne
parle pas en revanche
la russie n'avait aucun moyen de mettre
fin à ses attaques à partir du moment
une un accord de défense est signé
la russie peut intervenir et c'est ça ce
qui s'est passé toutes proportions
gardées en géorgie lorsque la russie a
reconnu l'indépendance des républiques
d'abkhazie et d'ossétie du sud
les attaques géorgiennes ont
automatiquement cessé parce
qu'effectivement là il ne s'agit pas il
ne s'agissait pas d'attaquer deux
petites républiques il s'agissait
effectivement de s'en prendre la russie
jean